[Music]
so time for the press preview then we're
going to see what is on the front pages
of monday's papers and tonight we'll
check out the headlines with the
financial times political correspondent
jasmine cameron chaleshi and the editor
of the jewish chronicle jake wallace
simons there they both are we'll chat to
them shortly after we've had a look
ourselves at those front pages beginning
with the telegraph leading with the
breaking news tonight that foreign
secretary liz truss has joined the
conservative leadership battle
and the times says home secretary pretty
patel is about to join her in the fight
for number 10.
the eye leads with a prediction that the
final run-off will be between rishi
sunak and one of the other candidates
who've declared so far
meanwhile the ft says that the senior
party figures running the election are
planning to thin out the field of
candidates more quickly by raising the
number of mps they each need to support
their nomination 1922 committee yet
making those decisions tomorrow the
guardian leading with leaked files which
seem to show how cap company uber
courted top politicians to help it fight
europe's established taxi industry
between 2013 and 2017
uber says its behavior then wasn't in
line with present values and it's a
different company today the mirror leads
with the worsening crisis in the
ambulance service with weights of up to
27 hours at a e
and finally the star leads with one of
its favorite subjects the latest
heatwave and how it's putting people off
going to work hawaii skivo
and don't forget you can scan the qr
code at any time that you see on screen
join the program and you can look at the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you're watching us discussing them and
i'm joined tonight by jasmine cameron
chaleshi political correspondent of the
financial times and jake wallace simons
editor of the jewish chronicle very good
to see this sunday evening um
now lots to discuss uh why don't we
start jasmine at the front of the daily
telegraph they have the the news this
evening that liz trust foreign secretary
is uh joining the race she's going to
slash corporation tax reverse national
insurance reform business rates uh
cutting taxes from day one
i mean it's quite unsurprising and that
there have been rumors that um liz trust
has been eyeing up a leadership campaign
for quite a while there was the sort of
rumored um fizzwood liz um meetings that
she would hold with backbenchers to try
to suss out their support but yeah so
this is a very unsurprising pitch um i
think it's quite interesting that really
the conservative race for leader is
really being framed as sort of like a
fight for the the soul of the party i
think there's a real sense that
conservativism under johnson sort of
lost its way and actually you see in
their their pitches that they're really
trying to
um sort of pull the party back to its
traditional conservative routes to see
that the fact that a lot of the
candidates have put their pictures in
the telegraph and also i think we've
seen a real sort of back and forth over
taxes so trust is one of many candidates
that has outlined her economic vision
for the country and i think there was a
frustration among tory mps that actually
under johnson the party had become a big
government party a party that was
comfortable raising taxes and sort of in
contrast to what you would expect of the
conservative party and many conservative
mps were sort of
very concerned with the national
insurance height the corporation tax
hike expected next year so i think she
is one of many mps that are sort of
outlining their their pledge to slash
taxes to
change the economic direction of the
country yeah i was going to say um and
then there were 10 for number 10 jake
but uh in the last half an hour uh
raymond chishti uh mp junior foreign
office minister has also said he's
standing this list is getting longer and
longer and so far the debate has been
about taxation as jasmine was saying uh
many of those candidates saying they're
going to cut taxes but there does need
to be clarity doesn't there if you're
saying we're going to cut taxes you need
to also say what what spending you're
going to cut shortly
that's right well i think that i mean
the thing about tax is that that's the
total for the tory party membership uh
the tories are supposed to be a low tax
party uh and at the moment the tories
are a high tax party i mean if we had
elected jeremy corbyn in 2019 this is
the sort of future that people were
anticipating of having taxes at a
70-year high and here we are with the
tory government
forcing this upon upon the british
people and so it's no surprise that
candidate after candidate is lining up
uh to pledge to cut tax in different
ways be it vat or to reverse national
insurance hike or fuel duty or whatever
but the only candidate that's finding it
difficult to to make that pledge of
course is rishi sunak he's the only
person to have served as chancellor and
he has been part of the government
that's president over such high taxes um
over the past few years um and and his
uh his approach is very much that you
know we can only bring taxes down once
we're out of this period which won't cut
it i fear with the uh with the tory
membership
let's look at the uh front of the ft it
just shows how quickly uh events are
changing uh jasmine the uh
the ft saying here nine in race so far
well of course now we know uh it's 11 uh
things have changed in just in the last
hour um and they are uh uh talking in in
their front page story about uh what the
1922 committee is planning to do their
meeting tomorrow to set the rules for
this contest and
with so many in the race and with summer
uh recess approaching that one wanting
to get on with this as quickly as
possible
yeah i think there really is a sense of
wanting to speed up the process and not
wanting to have a competition wherever
tom dick and harry's throws their hat
into the ring and i do think there is a
general feeling that while johnson is is
prime minister there's a sense that the
government is is in office but not
really in power and can't really get any
of these key policies done and so while
i think there's definitely a desire to
have a quick process i think actually
what we're going to see is an
increasingly bitter process because i
think
i mean first of all this isn't just a
competition for the the um leadership of
the conservative party it's obviously
the prime minister so it's quite high
stakes but also i think that the
conservative party at the moment is
pretty divided and people are sort of
forming into these quite tribal camps
and we saw it was pro boris anti boris
now it seems to be prosonic
anti-synagogue and there is a sense that
the new leader is really going to have
to unify these different wings of the
party and i do think tory mps in whether
they're in the 1922 committee or
backbenchers or all ministers i think
there is a real understanding that the
public are frustrated with the
conservative party at the moment we've
had party gate we've had um paterson
we've had all these harassment stories
we know that the party is slipping in
the polls so there is so this um contest
doesn't genuinely feel quite high state
i think there is a sense of just wanting
candidates forward and getting it done
as quickly as possible yeah let's have a
look at from the daily mail on that very
topic rishi caught in cummings toxic
smears storm
we had that smear accusation by nadeem
zahawi today i mean there is going to be
more uh talk of uh dossiers being handed
to labor with skeletons in the in the
closet i mean there's a danger here jake
that the tories really are going to pull
themselves apart with all this blue on
blue fighting
that's right i mean let's lately the
tories are emerging uh from a period
that's been defined uh largely by
sleeves i mean there are four tories
tory mps who've been lost to uh
accusations of sexual abuse with one
accused of rape and this seems to be
more of the same and the fact that the
um that the field is so crowded for the
leadership race uh means that this sort
of tendency to bri to brief brutally
against your direct competitors is
exacerbated i mean we've had as you've
said dossier's passed to labor officials
in in pubs in soho we've had private
investigators allegedly hired by some
candidates teams to get dirt on other
kansas teams um we've had you know
what's that messages circulating about
all sorts of compromise and accusations
and gossip and slurs swirling around and
the race is only a few days old you know
how much more is going to come before
the 21st of july when we go to the final
two
um
we've talked about tax today there are
other uh issues which are going to come
up in coming weeks jasmine gender
identity um uh
foreign affairs as well um what do you
think
about personality in this race how
important is that going to be
i mean i think it will be crucial i
think we've come from a period of we've
had some a figure like johnson he was
known for being very charismatic very
bombastic and i feel like the
these things always tend to move in
cycles and that we have a charismatic
leader followed by a slightly boring one
you had the um
the david cameron then you had the maid
and you have the johnson and so i do
feel like potentially there's an
appetite for
perhaps a more slightly quote-unquote
boring figure maybe uh maybe a um tom
tegan hat maybe a jeremy hunt but i
think crucially the one of the key
things that the new kansai will need to
establish whoever they are is i feel
like they'll need to win back the trust
of tory mps and the public we've had
several months of sleaze stories and
there's been a real sense that
under johnson's government it sort of
had quite a slippery relationship with
the truth and sort of the rules and i
think whoever the new person is they
will have to establish that their
administration is one that is going to
play it by the rules he's going to play
it by the letter and that actually they
can be trusted whether it's a minister
coming out in the morning round and
communicating to the public whether it's
the spokesperson communications
journalists i think establishing trust
will be the crucial thing regardless of
their personality yeah quick thought on
this
from you jake i mean who who do you
think can can cut through and make it
make it to the to the final two
goodness me well that's that's a very
difficult question i mean that the male
is saying that it's going to be rishi
tuna against another uh i think that
could be true but i think that we need
to take a lot of care to look at what's
happening on tory right at the moment
it's a very crowded field you've got
kenny baddenac a very sound voice on the
right you've got swella brahman as well
competing for the same support you've
got liz trust who was a romania but he's
nonetheless reinventing herself as a
candidate of the right and pretty
patella as well just sort of testing the
water and seeing if she can uh manage to
gain enough support to be the
representative of the right and with all
of these people vying for the same sort
of space uh blood will be left quite
quickly and you'll you'll begin to find
a a candidate to represent the tory
right emerge to uh to be up against
wishes sooner in the final two
okay we will leave it there and head to
a break coming up after that break we're
going to be discussing more of
tomorrow's headlines including this
story it's on the front of the guardian
the uber files leak reveal secret
lobbying operation to conquer the world
discussing that more in a couple of
minutes
[Music]
uh welcome back part to the press
preview jasmine and jake uh still with
us at jasmine front page of the guardian
i mean this is quite the story isn't it
guardian exclusive uh what about uber
yeah so it's quite an extraordinary
investigation so the paper has got hold
of i think it's over a hundred thousand
documents um
spanning between 2013 and 2017
looking at communications between uber
and uber's executives
and sort of leading political figures
and it really builds a picture of quite
an interconnected web of uber
executives liaising with macron when he
was economy minister liaising with
senior officials in the european
commission
all to bolster the influence of uber or
to help the company grow if we remember
actually this was at a period when the
company was it was you know it was still
trying to establish itself it wasn't the
mega giant that it was and it's now
today and it sort of raises all sorts of
questions as to how uber had such access
to some of these political figures and
why that was allowed to happen and the
ways in which the company grew so yes
it's a striking investigation i think it
will raise a lot of eyebrows especially
in in france um you know obviously
macron was a minister now he's prime
minister and it speaks to his sort of
you know it's one thing being
pro-business it's another thing being on
first name terms with some of these
leading executives and helping them push
their agenda yeah jake i mean it's so
revolutionary wasn't it uber but perhaps
it came at a cost
that's right i mean this all comes from
a time when uber was locked in a fight
to the death with the continents uh cab
industry the traditional taxi drivers
particularly in france there were
protests against uber as you'll recall
uh and uber basically eventually won i
mean uber is a ubiquitous brand now uh
it's worth hundreds of millions of
pounds uh per year and it seems like it
gained that victory partly by spending
90 million pounds a year on this
sophisticated lobbying effort by which
it allegedly got uh politicians of the
highest caliber and the highest ranks of
politics in its pocket
including allegedly emmanuel macron and
other european uh politicians who were
accused of being in a revolving door
relationship leaving politics going to
uber and back again um and often uh
giving pledges to the company that they
would make law reforms to favor it above
the tax industry so these are very
damning revelations as well um indeed uh
and uh and a lot of people will be re
opening their copy of the guardian and
reading it with their jaws on the floor
and dropping their marbles on the floor
this morning yeah this is what uber say
uh they say its behavior then wasn't in
line with present values and it is a
very different company uh today and
let's finish with uh novak djokovic uh
yet another remarkable win jasmine at
wimbledon
yeah so i think it's his fourth
consecutive title um so yeah i mean
he's
he's renowned for his his tennis playing
skills i can't i can't claim to be an
avid tennis watcher but even i can
appreciate someone who's pretty skilled
at what you know what they were doing
but i think it was his um
um his combative i think it was nick
kuros i think that's what pronounced his
name and his quite
you know interesting um tirade against
the fan that i think shocked people the
most my understanding is that he was
criticizing the fan for how much they
drunk and yeah i can imagine it was
shocked onlookers including the royal
family who were in attendance i think uh
jake tennis fan
it was a fascinating final wasn't it i
mean seventh consecutive uh wimbledon
victory for for jockovich not
consecutive but the seventh victory uh
it was a fascinating game and as
and as jasmine uh points out uh curios
really was the the wild card making it
into the final as a result of nadal
being injured uh not by winning the
semi-final and then going on to from
this extraordinary display which we kind
of expected of bad temper and swearing
and yelling and at the end being so
sportsman like sportsman's like we lost
big smile on his yeah and um he went off
yeah and sue barker retiring of course
another uh big shock